herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren heute geht es nun wirklich ans
eingemachte es geht um leben und tod um
sinn und unsinn unserer existenz
meingast muss ich ihnen nicht vorstellen
sie alle kennen ihn es ist der berühmte
extrembergsteiger und grenzgänger
reinhold messner herzlich willkommen
ja eigentlich sollten wir jetzt nicht
hier eine stunde sitzen sondern
spazieren gehen weil es sie meinen ja
die guten gedanken kommen wenn man
unterwegs ist
das ist wahr und wenn ich schreibe und
nicht weiterkomme oder ja es nicht
hinkriege was ich eigentlich will dann
gehe ich einfach in den wald hinaus und
spazieren stück und dann kommen die
klaren gedanken und warum ist das weil
wir menschen vermutlich zuerst den kopf
leer machen müssen um sozusagen wieder
neue werden neue gedanken klare gedanken
kriegen können
aber wir die richtig großen gedanken
reicht spazierengehen nicht da muss man
in unmenschliche gebiete dahin oder
mensch eigentlich nicht hingehört sagen
sie an die eigene grenze auch an die
grenze zum tod
und da erfährt man was der mensch
eigentlich ist warum ist das so als ihre
ansicht allerdings nur im hinterher
also wenn ich jetzt wirklich in die ganz
große höhe gehe wird ja auch das gehirn
nicht mehr voll durchblutet und da oben
sind wir ziemlich zombie haft
wir haben da keine großen eingebungen
wir kommen nicht als erleuchtete zurück
wie das oft dargestellt wird
aber in der summe im rückblick haben wir
eine möglichkeit über unser dasein zu
reflektieren wie es sonst nicht möglich
ist wir gehen ja freiwillig aus der
zivilisierten welt die relativ sicher
ist der mensch tut seit 10.000 jahren
nichts anderes als die welt seine urbane
umgebung sicherer und sichern und sicher
zu machen
da gehen wir hinaus in eine
menschenfeindliche welt wo man umkommen
könnte
um nicht umzukommen das ist ja das ist
wichtig dass diese möglichkeit bleibt um
zu kommen wenn die möglichkeit nicht die
möglichkeit um zu kommen nicht vorhanden
ist ist das ganze nur ein spiel aber
wenn die möglichkeit umzukommen gegeben
ist dann gehe ich ja gegen meine
instinkte in die wildnis ich die
instinkte wollten das nicht die sagen du
hast angst und ich habe auch angst und
sorgen trotzdem durch sich gegen den
selbsterhaltungstrieb das ist das
stärkste trieb den wir haben da hinauf
um nicht umzukommen und wenn es mir
gelingt nicht umzukommen ist das
anschließend wie eine wiedergeburt und
das ist vermutlich der hintergrund warum
wir das immer wieder tun dass da eine
art wiederholungszwang auftritt ich sage
nicht eine sucht da sind ja keine opiate
im spiel höchstens körpereigene aber es
hat einen wiederholungszwang in sich
weil dieses wiedergeboren sein dieses
gefühl wieder geboren zu sein
ein sehr starkes gefühl ist was ist das
für ein gefühl können sie das noch näher
beschreiben
ich habe das ganze leben vor mir wie ich
habe das ganze ja wieder auszufüllen ich
kann mein leben mit neuen ideen
ausfüllen
ich habe es mir selber erobert ich
glaube das hat damit zu tun dass das
selbsterhaltungstrieb kurz betrogen wird
wird betrügen uns selber
selbsterhaltungstrieb wird mehr oder
weniger nicht ausgeschaltet sondern
verschoben bevor wir los gehen
dann erleben wir das ganze kommen zurück
haben es also geschafft den
selbsterhaltungstrieb ein schnippchen zu
schlagen
und dafür werden wir belohnt mit diesem
großartigen gefühl das ganze leben ist
vor uns alles ist offen und wir leben
legen das leben ein zweites mal ein
drittes mal in die waagschale
es gab aber auch seltene momente wo sie
dieser selbsterhaltungstrieb verlassen
hat schreiben sie in ihrer autobiografie
zum beispiel am nanga parbat da haben
sie sich mit dem tod angefreundet haben
losgelassen sie schreiben dass sterben
war eine selbstverständlichkeit geworden
ein erlösendes erlebnissen ich frage
mich ist es letztlich das worum es im
leben geht sterben zu lernen und sich
mit der
endlichkeit abzufinden also sterben zu
lernen ist natürlich ein grosser wert
wenn ich mir bewusst werden dass sich
ein sterbender bin und das bin ich im
grunde seit der geburt dann kann ich das
leben intensiv erleben wenn ich so leben
als wäre ich ewig werde ich nicht so
intensiv leben und dem tibetischen
totenbuch steht da drinnen wir nicht
gelernt hat zu sterben kann auch nicht
leben so radikal würde ich das nicht
sagen aber es ist wesentlich die
erfahrung zu machen dass wir sterben de
sind und meine erfahrung in diesen
wenigen momenten in denen nicht beim
sterben war war es wirklich so dass dann
nicht mehr diese energie da war sich
festzukrallen festzubeißen im leben
sondern als es keine hoffnung mehr gab
das leben zu retten bevor ich ohnmächtig
wurde zum beispiel am nanga parbat
da war es eine erleichterung sozusagen
sich fallen zu lassen in den tod fallen
zu lassen
es war eine erleichterung ich kann nur
von dieser erfahrung sprechen erlösung
sagen sie sogar das ist ein religiös
konnotierte es ist eine erlösung ja aber
ohne jetzt zu sagen ich fange jetzt in
den himmel hinein oder ins jenseits
sondern einfach damit ist es am ende
meine energie es aufgebraucht die
hoffnung das leben retten zu können ist
null so lange ich das leben retten kann
hänge ich mit allen fasern die ich habe
mit dem wilden mit den zähnen mit den
krallen wenn ich noch welche habe am
leben das selbsterhaltungstrieb ist
unser stärkster treiber aber früher oder
später erkennen wir es ist vorbei und
damit wird das sterben kein problem mehr
wir menschen haben hier nicht angst vor
dem tod ist eine tatsache wir wissen
alle dass er am ende auf uns wartet oder
kommt aber sie haben angst vorm sterben
wir haben angst vor dem sterben weil wir
angst haben dass wir dabei leiden dass
wir dabei ja dahin siechen dass
irgendwelche probleme auftauchen
wir haben angst vor dem sterben aber
nicht angst vor dem tod
das möchte ich noch besser verstehen was
passiert auf diesen dass diese dieser
höhe oben also über 8000 meter wir haben
ins archiv geguckt haben ein paar bilder
gefunden wo man sie und peter hyballa
beim aufstieg auf den mount everest
sieht 1978 und sie haben gesagt man wird
so etwas wie ein zombie kann sie das
genauer war was passiert mit dem körper
auf diesen höhen
also das ist im grunde ganz einfach da
oben ist der sauerstoff partialdruck so
gering dass der mensch im grunde kaum
noch leistung bringen kann und
umzusteigen brauch ich leistung das
heißt ich muss sauerstoff zum blutzucker
bringen
das ist brennt das ich kraft habe dass
ich den körper wärmen kann
das ist alles auf ein minimum reduziert
die wissenschaft dass die medizin und
die physiologie waren ja der meinung des
1978 der mensch können maximal bis auf
8500 meter steigen und dann wäre schluss
war reiter kann er nicht dann ist er
gezwungen zurück zu gehen also
abzusteigen sauerstoffreiche luft oder
ja er stirbt und man hat uns ja
vorausgesagt wir werden darum kommen
oder nicht mehr zurückkommen und damit
nicht mehr zurückkommen oder wir müssen
den verstand verlieren ja es gibt
kritiker die sagen man könnte mir
feststellen
ich würde man gleich sagen sie hätten
vorher schon den verstand verloren aber
nein die haben das genutzt und zu sagen
so hat er sich ja selber außerhalb des
intellektuellen menschen gestellt
gut das ist nicht das problem da oben
sterben kehren sollten das ist sicher
aber nicht so viele dass man nachher als
trottel herunter gehabt im dialekt
südtirol ist aber es ist wirklich
schwierig da oben sich zu bewegen und es
ist nicht nur so dass meine muskeln
meine beinmuskeln die mich eben nicht
mehr energie haben weil kein sauerstoff
zum blutzucker kommen oder zu wenig
sauerstoff sondern auch mein gehirn wird
nicht mehr voll blut und das ist auch
mein wille da ja in meinem gehirn steckt
lässt nach die entscheidungsfreude die
beurteilungs fähigkeit und nur ein
minister der seine
sein tun schlafwandlerisch beherrscht
kann da oben weiter kommen und das war
unsere kraft peter hyballa ist ein
schlafwandlerisch sicherer absteiger
deswegen bei remy alle partner für den
mount everest wir schauen uns die wähler
noch mal ganz kurz haben wir haben die
vorbereitete werde vom aufstieg nicht
interessiert was passiert bei ihnen
jetzt wenn sie das nochmal sehen
bekommen ähnliche empfindungen hoch oder
ist das einfach so weit zurück und so
was anderes das ist weit weg und weit
zurück und ich hab's ja auch nur mehr in
diesen bildern präsent das heißt dieses
bild das ich aufgenommen habe mit einer
kleinen kamera also das ist peter habe
da aber am gipfel des mount everest
man sieht auf der einen seite diesen ja
doch froh den gesichtsausdruck aber auf
der anderen seite sieht man auch wenn
man das länger anschaut das zombie haft
ist schüttelt sich herankommen
ein roboter beiler mit letzter mildes
kraft diese schritte zum gipfel getan
hat man wird nach oben hin immer
langsamer weil das sauerstoff
partialdruck immer weiter abnimmt und am
ende war es bei uns so dass der gipfel
damit in unserer vorstellung immer
weiter weg rückte mit jedem schritt nach
oben wurden wir langsamer und damit den
stand dieses gefühl der gipfel geht von
uns weg da wird immer weiter weg wir
kommen wenn ihm näher aber läuft immer
davon und damit kamen hoffnungslosigkeit
ab und nur mit dem wissen wir sind immer
noch nach oben steigen töten mit messer
verglichen mit der uhr war klar wir
müssen früher oder später darauf kommen
weil sonst stimmt ja die rechnung
sie sagen das entscheidende bei diesem
höhenbergsteigen ist weder talent noch
ausdauer noch kraft sondern die
leidensfähigkeit und von der haben sie
sehr viel was haben sie für ein
verhältnis zum schmerz also ich bin kein
mensch der jetzt den schmerz sucht aber
leidenschaft hat mit leidensfähigkeit
auch zu tun
in der leidenschaft schon im begriff
steckt leiden
und wer meint das ganze sein spiel der
soll es machen also nicht heute bruders
präpariert wird für massen aufschläge
von und bezogen mit sauerstoff der
posten mit lacken versehen mit schärpen
mit köchen versehen
das ist auch anstrengend aber es hat
nichts zu tun mit selbst verantworteten
bergsteigen am ende der welt wo nix
präpariert ist also ich gehe in die
wildnis und ich weiß was ich in einer
gefährlichen situation unterwegs bin und
ich bin eigenverantwortlich unterwegs da
sagt nicht das gesetzbuch sondern das
weiß ich einfach wenn ich einen fehler
mache dann ist todesstrafe dann komme
ich nicht mehr runter und in dieser in
dieser situation sich zu bewegen ist
etwas anderes als in einer organisierten
welt sich zu bewegen
ja ja sie sagen auch in diesen
extremsituationen grenzsituationen
kommen arabische treppe hoch oder
instinkte und auch aggressionen und
soweit eine unglaubliche kraft bei ihnen
woher kommt das denn
also wenn wir in philosophische gehen
dann ist es relativ leicht zu
beschreiben wir leben in einer
archaischen welt dort um die welt war
bevor der mensch kam das ist einfach
absolute wildnis bevor der mensch zum
menschen wurde lebt er auch als ja nicht
als homo sapiens sondern als waffe
vermutlich irgendwo in der wanne und
lebte nur nach seinen instinkten im
laufe der jahrhunderte tausende sind wir
zum homo sapiens sapiens geworden nun
katapultiere ich mich freiwillig aus der
zivilisierten welt heraus die der mensch
geschaffen hat für sich um möglichst
viele menschen weiter zu bringen also am
leben zu halten und gehe dorthin wo der
mensch nicht hingehört und da bin
damit bin ich in einer archaischen
situation und es gibt keinen gesetzgeber
mehr da oben kann ich tun was ich will
also man selbst ja meine menschen natur
zwingt mich so und so zu handeln weil
die menschennatur bild dass ich
überleben
und ich lebe nach anarchischen mustern
würden sie sagen man entdeckt darin den
wahren menschen ich behaupte mann an
deck die ware menschennatur aber das ist
doch nur diese tierische menschennatur
man könnte auch sagen der mensch ist
eben wesentlich ein kulturwesen ja das
akzeptiere ich auch und hier in dieser
breite boot sitzen
bin ich ein kulturwesen aber da oben bin
ich eben
animalisches wesen und das animalische
das instinktive ist mindestens so
wichtig für unser dasein wie eben die
kultur die wir uns erarbeitet haben
mit den regeln die wir haben mit einer
ausdrucksmöglichkeit die wir haben
ich drücke mich auch damit außer nicht
auf diese berge hinaufsteigen
das ist auch eine möglichkeit nicht
auszudrücken meine fähigkeiten
auszudrücken
eine eine route in einer großen wand
braucht der not waren zum beispiel 1938
erstmals gelegt ist ein kunstwerk das
hat jemand in der natur gezeichnet 3500
meter lang ist dieser weg durch die
eigernordwand wie in heckmair gefunden
hat und das ist für mich wirklich ein
kunstwerk
ja sie sagen es ist sozusagen fantasie
ist was ganz zentrales nämlich die
eigene linie zu finden
ein berg hoch zu steigern und zu
zeichnen so zu sagen aber das liegt ja
man fantasie sondern ich lege diese
linie nach meinen bergsteigerischen
erfahrungen und nach der natur des
berges die natur des berges gibt mehr
beobachtet aus einer bestimmten distanz
genau vor wo ich am besten klettern kann
aber ich brauch natürlich meine
erfahrungen dazu und ein anderer tag
strecke hat eine andere erfahrung und
legt vielleicht eine andere linie am
ende sehen die menschen von der kleinen
scheidegg aus diese linie nicht aber bei
mir bleibt sich der richtig geklettert
habe ein leben lang bei mir ist präsent
als nicht greifbares als die schöpfung
des nichts aber das nichts ist das
großartigste was es gibt ich habe gerade
gehört in der zeitung gelesen dass man
den loro den ayers rock in australien
nicht mehr besteigen lässt in ab
nächstes jahr glaube ich war da oben ich
habe einige erstbegehungen gemacht
damals war es erlaubt die einheimischen
sehen das nicht gern das verstehe ich
warum weil sie sagen dort ist ein
heiliger platz 1 mythologischer platz
und dort wohnte dass nichts wirklich
großartig dass nichts nämlich kann man
füllen mit jede menge ideen mit kunst
mit mit visionen
mit lebenshaltungen ja dass nichts hat
viel mit dem tod auch zu tun und mit der
freiheit diese diese offenheit in diese
kleine gehen
ich frage mich noch meine wir haben kurz
über die schmerzen gesprochen über
diesen zustand über leidensfähigkeit
aber die angst dass noch was anderes
angst die man spürt todesangst wie gehen
sie ganz konkret damit um wie überwinden
sie diese angst lenken sie sich ab oder
die angst ist eine kraft eine eine
positive kraft wirklich sage ich immer
die vor allem im vorfeld auftaucht
während des tons ist die angst mehr oder
weniger aufgehoben vor allem während
gehsteige und klettern weil ich ja
völlig in dem was ich tue aufgehe
das ist dieser frau nämlich in diablo
oder auch die konzentration auf den
nächsten schritt
und in dem moment wenn ich den nächsten
schritt machen und nicht gerade
ausrutscher warum soll ich angst haben
wenn etwas passiert dann in der mine
kommt oder ein stein kommt von oben dann
ist es plötzlich ein schrecken das was
anderes aber im vorfeld bevor ich diese
unternehmungen mache diese abenteuer
diese grenzgänge angehe
muss ich das ganze jahr planen das
dauert oft nicht monate sondern jahre
lang und da kommen die ängste sehr
interessant die ängste wachsen wenn ich
da warte wenn nicht nicht losgehen wenn
ich mal losgegangen bin schrumpfen die
ängste das erkennt jeder abenteurer
bender das war jahrelang gemacht hat das
kennen wir vielleicht alltagssituationen
richtet im vorfeld einer prüfung ist man
nervös wenn man schreibt geht es so ist
und wenn ich jetzt daheim 3 1 früh
aufwache weil ich vorhabe die antarktis
zu durchqueren und plötzlich ängste
kommen was tue ich wenn der koffer nicht
mehr geht dann habe ich vielleicht noch
drei tage zu leben weil ich schnell
schmerzen muss um genügend flüssigkeit
zu haben
das habe ich getan das ist mir passiert
genau das
also ich bin immer wieder aufgewacht
irgendetwas funktioniert nicht
hauptsächlich der kocher funktioniert
nicht es ziemlich ein komplexes ding
dass komplexes ding
dann habe ich überlegt gut ich kann zwei
koffer mitnehmen können auch gleich
kaputt gehen drei kochen ja irgendwo
muss ein ende haben
das kann ich nicht mehr ziehen dann habe
ich gelernt meinen koffer in hundert
teile zu zerlegen und wieder zusammen zu
stellen und zu schauen ob noch
funktioniert und dass ich das konnte den
kocher zerlegen war dieses problem also
diese ängste im vorfeld des unternehmens
weg und die ängste sind ja unserer
gartenzaun der und sagt bis hierher und
nicht weiter
und wir müssen es schaffen mit training
mit logistik mit vorbereitung mit dem
richtigen partner
diese ängste mehr oder weniger zu
kontrollieren es bleibt immer ein
restrisiko
es bleiben immer bestimmte sorgen bevor
man losgeht
auch wenn ich es dann nicht los zu gehen
dann kann ich nicht einmal scheitern und
das braucht für das abenteuer in erster
linie die gabe oft zu wagen was durch
den in meinem leben ich habe nichts
anderes getan als sie beten oder
visionen die ich in meinem kopf
entwickelt habe in die tat umzusetzen
sie sagen die gabe es zu wagen ja dafür
an kanzler nicht lernen
man kann es nicht lernen zur endmontage
ist berühmt geworden als der
erstbesteiger des mount everest weil er
es gewagt hat er war nicht vorgesehen
als neuseeländer bei einer englischen
expedition den höchsten berg der welt
das letzte ziel von geografischen wert
auf dieser erde zu erreichen
aber man weiß ja aber die engländer
wollten das schon selber machen
die engländer haben ja am nordpol vielen
menschenleben geopfert um ihn als erster
zu erreichen haben wir nicht erreicht am
südpol sind sie zu spät gekommen und die
ganze mannschaft ist beim zurückgehen
mit robert falcon scott umgekommen
die norweger werden vorher dort mit
annoncen und jetzt hatten sie 1953 den
everest als letztes geografisches ziel
und haben dieses ziel verfolgt wie
später die amerikaner die mondfahrt also
haben sie alles investiert die besten
leute wollten engländer auf den gipfel
bringen
die engländer haben es versucht
das sind nicht hinausgekommen und haben
knapp vor dem gipfel halt gemacht und
carmen zurückbilden und eben sassen die
beiden männer und haben in einem
vorgeschobenen basislager beim
brainstorming mit dem expeditionsleiter
gesagt das ist nicht möglich das letzte
stück ist unmöglich
und dann gab es eine diskussion und
niemand hat sich gemeldet und gesagt
wenn die beiden stärksten gescheitert
sind brauchen wir nicht versuchen und
dann erst meldet sich im letzten moment
bevor man die expedition aufgibt und
weiß den nächsten die kommen würden sind
schweizer
die haben schon versucht die würden
wiederkommen die hätten vielleicht eine
chance sich das große ziel aber das
zuschnappen war damals natürlich von
allen stationen gewünscht dann meldet
sich hilary und sagt ich gehe unter zwei
bedingungen
man muss mir helfen das letzte lager
höher hinauf zu bringen dass ich eine
chance habe diese unmögliche passage in
ruhe anzugehen unmöglich und
anführungszeichen und ich nehme bitte
den partner meiner wahl und zwar nicht
einen engländer sondern ein sherpa einen
einheimischen der damals weder lesen
noch schreiben konnte aber motiviert war
und geschickt war
stichwort partner sie hatten ja mit
ihrem bruder ein kletterpartner und
haben ihn 1970 am nanga parbat verloren
eines der prägendsten erlebnisse ihres
lebens wahrscheinlich ich meine die
endlich die eigene endlichkeit ist das
eine aber die endlichkeit der anderen
ist das andere und mich interessiert wie
sind sie mit diesem verlust umgegangen
wie haben sie den verarbeiten können
also zuerst einmal war der verlust für
mich leichter zu ertragen als für meine
brüder wir sind eine große familie also
neun kinder eine schwester und acht
männliche kinder in der familie und am
schwierigsten war es natürlich für die
mutter das zu verkraften
ich habe es erlebt also wir haben
zusammen am nanga parbat aber der
höhenkrank knapp nach dem gipfel erst
erkennbar
vorher haben die es gar nicht gemerkt
und damit waren wir gezwungen etwas zu
tun was nicht vorgesehen war über eine
und bekannte route abzusteigen ohne sein
wir hatten beide kein seil weil wir
beide getrennt punkte als alleingänger
losgegangen waren
das war dann ein mehr oder weniger
unmögliches unterfangen dass wir
überhaupt herunterkamen bis an den
wandfuß ist näherungsweise ein wunder
und ich war voraus und im letzten stück
wie schon weiter oben einen ausweg zu
finden durch einen eisbruch also mit
gletscherspalten abbrüchen und ich
konnte meinen bruder nicht zumuten dass
er das tat was ich tun musste ein stück
gehen feststellen das geht nicht weiter
zurückgehen links schaden wieder
zurückgehen recht schaden und vielleicht
dann weiter kommen und wir haben das
sozusagen in einer art stafette gemacht
er hat gewartet bis sich ihm wieder
zeichen gab oder rufen konnte es geht
wieder ein stück und dann war wieder ein
gewitter voraus und am barren fonds ist
ein riesiger kessel also da kann man
herum laufen wenn man will ist auch
nicht gefährlich weil dort will die
spalten alle zu sind aber es gab
darunter noch so einen rücken wo die
spalten alle offen lagen die
gletscherbahnen seil über gletscher
gehen muss man austesten bis in die
feinheiten
ich war voraus und der rest von der band
herunter von einer lawine getroffen
worden
ich habe das gar nicht gesehen weil er
hinter meinem rücken war und dort
wartete und weiß ich zurückging und der
nicht kam und ich suchte war mir klar er
muss unter diesen trümmern liegen ich
konnte ihn natürlich nicht greifen also
nicht ausgraben und ich lebte dann in
dieser schizophrenie
auf der einen seite zu wissen mein
bruder des toten sabine eine klare
erkenntnis mit der ich mich abfinden
musste und ich habe mich auch damit
abgefunden
aber das blieb dann immer noch dieses
gefühl er ist irgendwo sogar ich höre
ihn rufen da ist irgendwo in der nähe
das heißt ich war dann zerrissen
zwischen einerseits wissen bruders tod
und darf der anderen seite eben diese
hoffnung die suggeriert er ist am leben
die mich genau hat und dann bin ich am
tag nach ja ich bin da oben am gletscher
herum gehört die ganze nacht und dann
natürlich auch ein geschlafen haben ihr
schlimmstes erfrierungen geholt in
dieser abstieg aber vor allem auch in
dieser nacht wo alle schon nass war von
diesem suchen
gletscher sind jetzt auf 5000 meter ich
kannte ist es da ein gipfelbereich war
zwischen 30 und 40 grad - sowie die
nacht verbrachten die erste nach und da
haben wir was sie zu essen da war gar
nicht da nichts wir hatten kein koch
keine getränke seit drei tagen zwei
tagen sind die summe habe ich fünf tage
lang ohne essen gelebt allerdings in den
letzten tagen dann gletscherwasser
getrunken
also sonst hätte ich nicht überlebt weil
der körper werden völlig dehydriert also
das ist nicht überlebt aber jetzt komme
ich nach hause schnell mal einen schluck
zu ja das ist richtig
jetzt komme ich nach hause und muss
natürlich diese geschichte erzählen und
für die mutter ist das sehr schwierig
die hat am ende der welt ohne
vorstellungs möglichkeit den sohn
verloren hat sich eine vorwärts gemacht
die mutter hat man ihm vorwürfe gemacht
ein riesiger skandal einfach erfunden
haben ich hatte den bruder irgendwo über
die andere zeit herunter geschickt aber
das ist jetzt mehr oder weniger
ausgestanden bruder gefunden wurden ist
35 jahre später und dann habe ich alle
meine brüder soweit sie physisch die
möglichkeit hatten und meine feste
eingeladen
ein spaziergang zur fundstelle zu kommen
um ihnen die möglichkeit zu geben
abschied zu nehmen von bruder zu
begreifen wo wie das ganze stattgefunden
hat vor ort ist das relativ schnell
gegriffen und begriffen also sozusagen
mit den händen gegriffen und begriffen
daheim kann man das nicht verstehen das
ist zu weit weg und denn in einer welt
die meisten menschen nicht präsent haben
wenn sie an den tod jetzt ihres bruders
oder ihres sohnes denkt sie haben dann
zwei jahre später am manaslu nochmal
zwei kollegen verloren und danach
beschlossen alleine zu gehen es alleine
zu versuchen in selbstverantwortung sind
aber gescheitert
richtig warum sind sie denn an der
einsamkeit gescheitert weil ich zu jung
war und noch nicht gelernt hatte mit mir
selber zurecht zu kommen
warum das ist sehr sehr schwierig es ist
auch nach wie vor kein 8000 mehr
wirklich allein
allein heißt ohne dass irgendjemand
anderer in der nähe ist oder eben am
berg ist wenn leute ein stück weit mit
einer menschen kolonne wie sie heute am
mount everest am manaslu come true
stattfinden hinauf geht es das ja kein
alleingang da bin ich eingebettet
zwischen anderen und gehalt wohne einen
eigenen partner aber mutterseelenallein
am ganzen berg ist viel schwieriger als
in partnerschaft weil wir die ängste und
die zweifel teilen wollen geteilt der
angst ist nurmehr halbe angst und wenn
ich allein darauf geworfen wenn hinauf
geworden bin ich war für mich selber
nach hinauf dann ist das das
hauptproblem die nicht die einsamkeit
sondern das nicht teilen können
die einsamkeit in der stadt ist etwas
völlig anderes auch schlimm für jemand
der das nicht gelernt hat mit sich
selber zurecht zu kommen
als weit weit weg in einer todes
intensiven umgebung das sind wir ja
einen todes intensiven umgebung und ich
brauchte bis 78 bis ich das konnte und
nachdem ich es gelernt hatte mit mir
selber zurecht so kann man hing auch mit
meinem privaten leben zusammen war ich
in der lage den nanga parbat allein zu
besteigen und später auch den mount
everest und habe am ende auch die wüste
gobi allein durchqueren wir haben hier
noch ein foto vorbereitet vom nanga
parbat 78 wo man sich auf den auf dem
gipfel sieht also sie haben dann das
irgendwie geschafft mit dieser
einsamkeit auszukommen und vor allem in
den nächten habe ich gelesen ist das
einfach auch schwierig wenn man da
warten muss und der held ihres neuen
buches wild frank war der muss ja auch
warten und ja haben die eine
antarktis-expedition gemacht 1914 mit
scheckkarten zusammen dass die sind das
schiff ging kaputt die sind dann im meer
von insel getrieben der schotte holt
hilfe und die männer unter anderem auch
frank wild müssen da ausharren in
eisiger kälte in nächten es ist dunkel
weiß nicht wie lange
was hat sie fasziniert an dieser figur
frank wild also zuerst einmal habe ich
bei meinen antarktis reisen ich habe ja
auf doch shackleton rote auf der
shackleton idee die antarktis durchquert
mit david fuchs zusammen
das kam weil ich shackleton und seine
geschichte kannte und wir haben das als
erster realisiert dass er damals nicht
machen konnte man das schiff kaputtging
und dieses trifft nach dem eis dann
stattfinden vielleicht das größte
abenteuer der menschheitsgeschichte
aber ich habe dann mehr und mehr
festgestellt dass in der ganzen
erzählungen shackleton als der alleinige
hält ford bis in unsere zeit vor allem
in den letzten 20 jahren wurde er behält
schlechthin der alle seine leute rettet
und dann habe ich hinter die kulissen
geschaut und haben wir das ganze vor ort
angeschaut elefant island wo die anderen
22 man einen ganzen winter lang hockten
und mit dem wissen dass das warten die
ängste steigert und das tun die ängste
minimiert habe ich dann die ganze
geschichte neu beleuchtet und neu
geschrieben und ich glaube dass meine
geschichte die wahre geschichte ist das
heißt shackleton flieht er geht weg
angst liegt sozusagen instrument um
natürlich auch hilfe zu holen wenn er
nicht gefahren wäre werden die alle
gestorben alle 28
er fährt raus aber er nimmt sich damit
die ängste und die zweifel sind da auch
zu sechst und überqueren am ende die
insel großartiges abenteuer
aber zurück zu bleiben ohne nichts mit
der hoffnung er kommt in vier wochen
spätestens also zwei wochen war
angekündigt nach vier wochen waren noch
nicht da und das wissen jetzt kann keine
hilfe mehr kommen
und der winter dauert vier monate lang
essen nur wenn man etwas schief truppen
oder pinguine keine richtige heizung bis
zu 50 grad - immer dunkel das wasser
spülte sozusagen über diese kleine
lagerstelle zwei umgekippte
rettungsboote wo sie darunter gehaust
haben
die männer waren so weit dass sie
kollektiven selbstmord planten um aus
dieser hölle herauszukommen das
schlimmste gefängnis das man sich
vorstellen kann
freiwillig hinein gegangen aber jetzt
eben gefängnis und da es ist eben frank
wild das war der zweite in command bei
dieser expedition zweite mann den
shackleton zurückgelassen hat mit einem
vertrag mit der klaren aussage du bist
der einzige der diese männer sozusagen
am leben halten kann
shackleton wusste das weil diese
fähigkeit hat menschen vertrauen zu
geben und das ist ihm gelungen es ist
ihm gelungen über vier monate hinweg die
leute am leben zu halten mit dem
vertrauen das sie in ihn hatten dass die
rettung am ende funktionieren wird und
dies ist meine geschichte dass ein buch
über vertrauen und ich möchte vor allem
erklären wie es im kleinen kreis
funktioniert mit dem vertragen wir haben
ja in unserer welt in der heutigen
europäischen welt nehmen wir nur die
europäische welt festzustellen dass das
vertrauen verloren geht in die
wirtschaftsführer in die politischen
führer sogar in die kulturträger
warum geht das vertrauen in die medien
informationen das vertrauen geht uns
verloren weil nach meinem dafür hatten
die empathie feld zwischen den
führungspersönlichkeiten zwischen der
liebte wie man das nennt und den
einfachen leuten nicht nur weil die
schere zwischen reich und arm immer
weiter auseinander geht das auch ein
grund aber es fehlt die empathie bei
denen die sich zu der elite gemacht
haben
berechtigterweise vermutlich und frank
wild war in der lage mit jedem nicht mit
leid zu teilen mit leider nicht immer
von oben sondern die einfach die
lebensängste die die hoffnungen
gezweifelt zu teilen erkannt konnte in
die anderen menschen in die psyche
hineingehen und mit jedem auf gleicher
ebene fühlen dazu führen dass eben diese
kleinen dimensionen nicht dass alles so
groß ist und diese großen massen und da
kein tätigen das vertrauen verloren also
ich kann natürlich nicht immer große
massen sprechen weil ich keine
erfahrungen dazu habe
ich benutze diese geschichte die ich
genau recherchiert habe erzählen sie
freien nach wie in einem roman um zu
erzählen wie funktioniert in einer
gruppe von 28 menschen mehr sind es
nicht
empathie sie selbst sind ja auch in
einer engen umgebung in einer kleinen
welt groß geworden 1944 geboren im
südtirol in vielen kleinen bäuerlichen
dorf aufgewachsen mit sieben brüdern
eine schwester einen strengen über
strengen vater vielleicht einer sehr
liebevollen mutter und 1968 wo die welt
repariert hat sex drugs and rock'n roll
waren sie am berg und haben da ihre
anarchie gelebte eigentlich war dass das
klettern ihre form sich aufzulehnen
gegen widerstände nicht unbedingt also
das blättern war nicht die farben der
auflehnung sondern die klettern war für
mich eine form des mich ausdrücken
ich war immer eher ein einsteiger als
ein aussteiger also ich bin eingestiegen
die wende
ich habe mein leben gewagt ich habe
damals 68 einen aufsatz geschrieben der
das dach steigen erschüttert hat
ernannte sich mord am unmöglichen wo ich
sozusagen meine grundidee darlege wenn
wir das unmögliche mit hilfe der
technologie die ja weiter entwickelt
wurde weiterentwickelt wurde heute ein
hubschrauber zum beispiel am berg die
größte hilfe und das gps gerät oder das
handy das sind alles große hilfe in der
bergsteigerei wenn wir die technologie
so weit einsetzen dass es kein unmöglich
mehr gibt er wird mit einem hubschrauber
auf das fliegen lassen dann ist drei bis
muss dort den drei meniskus hat immer
davon gelebt und damals war ich halten
ist in erster linie dass die junge
generation versucht hat das was die alte
generation als unmöglich deklariert hat
möglich zu machen
das hat ja auch immer das geklappt das
galt als unmöglich und es wurde nur zur
sensation weil das unmögliche so klar
festgeschrieben war
und wäre es dann möglich gemacht haben
wenn da nicht im vorfeld die physiologen
und der ärzte ob die bachstädter alle
gesagt hätten unmöglich unglücklich
selbstmord das kann nicht gehen wäre das
eine besteigung geworden wie viele
andere gehört auch nicht zu meinen zehen
schwierigsten bleibt ordentlich gemacht
habe aber es hat sozusagen das
unmögliche das damals festgeschrieben
war
als nicht unmöglich heraus gearbeitet
unsere besteigung und dieser dieser
aufsatz war viel wichtiger wenn meine
berg wurden ich habe im gleichen jahr 68
auch eine klettertour gemacht die über
zehn jahre lang niemandem erklärt und
konnte weil es so schwierig war
allerdings habe ich das nicht geplant
und gemeistert sondern eher in einer
verzweiflungstat ich konnte nicht mehr
zurück ich konnte nicht nach oben
also blieb mir nichts anderes übrig als
in einem akt der verzweiflung
die letzten reserven zu animieren und
das daneben zu schaffen war mein
schwierigstes klettertour ich je gemacht
habe ja diese grenzen sie bezeichnen
sich selbst als grenzgänger und
einerseits sind die äußeren grenzen das
was man für möglich und unmöglich hält
aber da habe ich viel wichtiger sind
ihnen die inneren grenzen an die man
immer wieder gehen soll und eine form
von selbstüberwindung kultivieren zoll
oder pflegen soll
was ist denn für sie da der reiz
überhaupt dieser oder das glück
vielleicht auch der selbstüberwindung
also von der knights würde ich nicht
sprechen sondern eher von von glück auch
nicht bewusst glück ist im großen ganzen
etwas was ich habe bei seine wenn ich es
nicht habe wenn ich ganz bei der sache
bin dann bin ich ein mensch der nicht
mehr nach dem glück fragt das heißt
glück erlebt man nie sondern man
vermisst das ja richtig also das glück
findet in jeder faser um so das dasein
statt wenn wir uns nicht mehr fragen
sind wir glücklich oder nicht da bin ich
ganz davon überzeugt
ich habe das glück gehabt als kind zum
bergsteigen zukommen fünfjährige habe
ich den ersten dreitausender bestiegen
mit den eltern und dem älteren bruder
mit 55 ja aber das ist jetzt ein zufall
und dann sind wir sehr früh in
eigenregie zum klettern gegangen daheim
in den dolomiten bürger groß geworden
sind großartige werke die geißler
spitzen mit dem ihr habt zuerst zu fuß
und später mit dem fahrrad an das ende
des tages und daneben da die wände
hinauf sie müssen sich vorstellen
ich war 16 mein bruder war 14 wir sind
um zwei uhr früh aufgestanden und 3 uhr
früh hat uns die mutter frühstück
gemacht und wir sind damit sein und
tatenlos gezogen und sie hat nie ihre
ängste gezeigt sie hat uns immer gehen
lassen wenn sie uns da gebremst hätte
dann werden wir nie selbständige
bergsteiger geworden aber in dieser zeit
zwischen meinem fünften und meinem
sechzehnten lebensjahr habe ich die
instinkte entwickelt die mich später
überlässt überleben ließen und nur weil
ich diese großartige diese großzügige
mutter hatte die uns haben ziehen lassen
oder die jungs haben erzählen lassen und
damit sind wir erstens zu bestimmten
erfahrungen gekommen und zu diesen
instinkten gekommen deren später dann
wirklich große schritte haben machen
lassen
im alpinismus und ich habe damals
wahrscheinlich im unterbewusstsein ich
kann es heute nicht sagen wann das
angefangen hat erkannt dass das leben
darin besteht die daten zu entwickeln
und diese umzusetzen
es gibt am lebensende kein gelungenes
leben im rückblick das ist zu spät
sondern es gibt nur im hier und jetzt
gelingen das leben während ich versuche
meine ideen umzusetzen aber wenn man das
ein leben lang macht dann kann man
rückblickend nicht sagen das war ein
gelungenes leben nein das ist nicht
wichtig warum habe ich nichts mehr
das heißt der moment zählt ja der moment
selbst im hier und jetzt leben umsetzen
deswegen durch habe ich mit 72 jahren
meine letzte aufgabe selbst gestellte
aufgabe
den alpinismus in einem museum zu
erzählen ein sechsteiliges museum das
frei wirtschaftlich funktioniert das
sich auf die beine gestellt habe das
einzige was mich nicht interessiert das
weiter zu betreiben und zu verwalten
sondern abgegeben das macht jemand
anderer eine tochter von mir
die kann das auch die hat das gelernt
ist kunsthistorikerin dies hat
wirtschaft studiert ich nicht ich habe
es nur auf die beine stellen wollen
und ich habe eine neue firma gegründet
die nennt sich ähnlich messner mountain
movie und die versuche ihre filme zu
machen
das heißt ich habe ideen zwar eine ganze
reihe die versuche hier zu passive
umzusetzen
und während des umsetzungs gibt es nicht
nur momente sondern phasen des glücks
wollte mich nicht mehr frage ob ich
glücklich bin sondern es entsteht etwas
ich tue was ich bin selber so zu sagen
da umsetzen
das möchte ich mit denen noch über einen
wichtigen philosophen sprechen wenn wir
über das glück oder auch über das
umsetzen sprechen über selbstüberwindung
es gibt von albert camus den
französischen existenzialisten den
aufsatz der mythos des sisyphos und
darin zeichnet er das bild von sisyphos
der diesen stein den ganz zeit diesen
bercow schleppen muss dazu ist er
verdonnert von den göttern und sobald er
oben ist holt dieser stein wieder runter
also es ist eine absurde aufgabe das
immer wieder zu machen neben ist sie
vors arbeit das ganze für kamine ein
bild unseres lebens das leben für
camille sinnlos ich frage mich sind sie
auch so ein sisyphos
also ich habe in dem film messner wenn
ein produzent und regisseur gemacht hat
ich war nur dann und wann piraten dabei
also eine biografie über mich
gebeten und man hat es auch getan die
ersten zeilen und die letzten zeigen von
diesem aufsatz ist ein längerer aufsatz
sich zu fuß hineinschreiben lassen
das ist können der letzte satz ist
überraschend wir müssen uns sisyphos als
einen glücklichen menschen vorstellen ja
dieser satz hört kommt sozusagen ist ja
dahin üblich bei dieser absolute navarra
etwas tut
trotz der qualität des lebens das leben
ist und jeden menschen wird klar wenn
jemand sagt ich habe die erste gruppe
durchquert oder ich will den everest
ohne maske besteigen dass das absurd ist
aber gerade weil es absurd ist ist es
das zu tun und auch glück bringendes zu
tun
also wenn ich in der absurdität des
lebens stehen bleiben und sagen meine es
ist absurd ich sitze hier ein ganzes
leben lang werde ich sicherlich nicht
das erreichen was andere sich unglück
vorstellen ist das eine form von sich
auflehnen revoltieren gegen dieses
absurde dasein das leben ist absurd und
nur weil es absurd ist lohnt es sich das
leben zu lernen
einerseits berlin gebe das würde es auch
schon was sind da sind dass da nicht
hinein spielten bei carmen kampa sind
auch nur am rande vor
das ist die absurde de von der er
spricht den sinn legen wir in unser
leben hinein und das ist unser gutes
recht
und hier kommt die auseinandersetzung
mit der religion
das heißt wenn mir die religion den sinn
vorgibt bin ich schon auf dem holzweg
das heim betrug wir menschen haben die
fähigkeit sinn zu stiften
wir haben eine zweite göttliche
fähigkeit das ist die kreativität das
sind die wiener fähigkeiten damit post
deutlich nicht an gott sondern damit
sage ich nur das sind fähigkeiten die
über das tierische animalische
hinausgehen und diese beiden fähigkeiten
nutze ich so starke ich in meinem leben
kann
je besser ich als sinnstifter bin ich
lege sinn in ein bestimmtes tun hinein
in eine bestimmte sache in eine
bestimmte person mehr wichtigkeit als
eine andere
damit bin ich ein sinnstifter und je
stärker richter bin umso weiter komme
ich dabei und umso größer ist mein
gelingendes leben ländliches nur wenn
ich aber dem sinn folge den anderen
postulieren bin ich auf dem holzweg das
erste was ihrem leben lernen müssen ist
zu erkennen dass wir das recht haben
wenn nicht die pflicht sind zu stiften
das ist diese diese idee von freiheit
von selbstbestimmung über das eigene
leben und letztlich auch eine form bei
ihnen von autarkie selbstgenügsamkeit
die sie aufsuchen ich fand bei der
vorbereitung am interessantesten was ich
gelesen habe sie sind eigentlich ein
vorsichtiger vielleicht sogar
ängstlicher mensch und sie suchen
sicherheit aber die suchen sie nicht in
zivilisationen kultur in beziehungen
sondern in sich selbst sie möchten
stärker werden selbst möchte selbst
mächtigkeit
warum verlassen sie sich nicht gerne auf
andere menschen auf die zivilisation
aufgesetzt politik warum nur sie also
ich lebe ja in der organisierten welt in
der zivilisation
ich war auf der straße rechts ich kenne
das alles an aber daten und warten bin
ich aus dieser welt heraus gegangen und
in eine ganze andere welt hinein
gegangen also noch keine gesetze gab das
ist im grunde ein zurückgehen eine zeit
als der mensch noch nicht so weit war
dass er in größeren gruppen zusammen
lebte da war die notwendigkeit dass man
regeln schafft der beginn religiöse
regeln und daneben demokratische regeln
in unserer heutigen zeit ich lebe ganz
normal als bürger in dieser welt und
mache verträge und mache ja auch meine
museumsarbeit war eine aber das haben
wir nicht die nötige sicherheit die sich
suchen diese existenzielle sicherheit
das hatte selbst mächtigkeit habe ich
mir in der wildnis geholt meine selbst
mächtigkeit ich war ja zwischen selbst
verschwendung und das selbstzerstörung
der möglichen selbstzerstörung unterwegs
freiwillig so wie der mensch 400.000
jahren jeder mensch 400.000 kann
er wusste das nicht aber es war so und
die kunst bei mir waren es eben an den
äußersten rand der mit meiner
möglichkeiten zu gehen und die
selbstzerstörung aufzuhalten
selbstzerstörung ist bisher nicht
passiert also ich lebe noch
ich habe man zwar ein paar zehner
abgefroren haben wir das fersenbein
zertrümmert das fersenbein zu hause
wahrscheinlich aber daheim damit wir da
wieder klar man muss nicht unbedingt auf
den everest besteigen um runter zu
fahren kann kann man auch von der
hausmacher runterfallen ja aber das ist
spannend was sie sagen heute in unserer
gesellschaft ist diese
sicherheitsbewusstsein viel zu groß also
sie sind sprechen auch von einer
absicherungs hysterie und schreiben in
ihrer sehr lesenswerten auto biografie
dass die politik den bürgern zu viel
verantwortung abgenommen hat und die
wohlfahrt demokratie eine sackgasse sei
können sie das erläutern so sicherheit
also man hat inzwischen festgestellt
nicht nur ich sondern auch
wissenschaftler
wenn der mensch über keine stolpersteine
mehr gehen muss dann verlernt das gehen
also es hat dann interessante
erfahrungen im letzten herbst in etwa
gemacht ich bin fast 50 jahre in den
himmel reißt nach neapel gereist
und in all diesen jahren war es so dass
ich auf diesen wanderwegen auf diesen
tracking roten bis zum fuße des berges
einheimischen begegnet bin sehr häufig
die gehen zu fuß mit anderen hast am
rücken und die größen jeden der kommt
jede die kommt mit namaste also man
faltet die hände und sagt namaste das
ist der dortige groß und übersetzt
bedeutet das ich begrüße das göttliche
indira demgegenüber sehr schöner groß
endlich wie grüß gott sage ich grüß gott
in naples sage ich auch im letzten
herbst ging ich noch solo compo drei
tage lang zu fuß durch bergauf bergab
kein mensch hat mir gegrüßt alle hatten
ein handy und stolperten über die steine
weil sie authentisch automodellen was
daten oder saßen am wegrand und haben
mit diesem
gerät gearbeitet gespielt gedanken wie
auch in europa über die gehsteige leute
ist auf dieses ende
wir werden mit der zeit völlig von der
realität weggeschoben
weil wir in einer virtuellen welt leben
mehr und mehr aber das sind wir doch
immer schon wir sind doch wiesen die
kleider haben wir haben kein fell zum
beispiel wir brauchen kultur zum
überleben das gehört auch zum menschen
dazu warum müssen wir diese
unabhängigkeit dieser innere stärke
wieder kriegen diese instinkte und
instinkte müssen wir nicht verloren
geben vielleicht brauchen wir sie wieder
ich habe auch die selbsterhaltung
selbstversorger landwirtschaft wieder
aufgebaut werden ich komme aus einer
bauern gegend und hatte den wunsch schon
mit 20 jahren mich selber versorgen zu
können und ich bin auf meinem heimatdorf
in das nur weg gegangen weil ich dort
keine landwirtschaft trägt dann habe ich
zufällig an eine burg gefunden die beim
verfall war die kostete 86 kaufen können
und darunter habe ich zwei jahre später
zwei landwirtschaften kaufen können
zum glück zufällig sehr günstig alles
kaputt verödet verstaucht von morgen
büsche habt ihr wieder aufgebaut und
haben mir eine selbstversorger
landwirtschaft zugelegt dich heute nicht
mehr selber mache ich hab drei höfchen
berghilfe südtirol und ich produziere
alles was wir zum leben brauchen holz
zum heizen bis zum fleisch gemüse obst
und das ist ein viel stärkeres
emotionales sicherheitskonzept als
irgendwelche papiere auf der bank aber
das hängt damit zusammen dass ich auf
dieser welt komme und ich bin der
meinung das darf nicht verloren gehen
wie am menschen sollten auch diese
dieses know-how uns bewahren für
eventuelle krisen bekommen können etwas
anderes das nicht verloren gehen darf
ist diese wildnis sie versetzen sich auf
ihren outen schutz 1 für eine gewisse
zone ab weiß ich nicht viel wie viel
tausend metern die einfach unberührt
bleibt von zivilisation das ist das eine
aber auch für umweltschutz
setzen sie sich ein und da vielleicht
noch die die radikale frage brauchen wir
angesichts des klimawandels ein völliges
umdenken in sachen verhältnis zur natur
messen unser verhältnis zur natur anders
denken damit wir das schaffen also die
der klimawandel ist ein problem das der
das in erster linie damit zusammen hängt
dass hier die welt nicht zusammenbringen
nicht trump ist gleich ausgestiegen aus
dem pariser louvre klimavertrag also
wenn die großen nationen die wirklich
sehr viel co2 ausstoßen china indien und
amerika das nicht einhalten
dann sind die europäer natürlich nicht
die die welt retten können
aber wir europäer sollten gemeinsam
schon als vorreiter zeigen dass wir das
ernst nehmen
in diesem zusammenhang das ist jetzt
große politik das jetzt brennt politik
da habe ich keinen einfluss aber
generell wir müssen unter anderem
verstehen dass die bildnis ein wert ist
der wildnis war früher ein werk also ein
mensch wollte keine wildnis haben er hat
nichts anderes getan als hunderttausend
jahre lang die bilden ist zurück
getrennt jetzt müssen wir erkennen die
wildnis ist ein wert wo wir bestimmte
erfahrungen machen können
deswegen sage ich als touristiker ich
bin ein touristiker das museum ist eine
touristische infrastruktur um eine
bauernhöfe funktionieren als
touristische infrastruktur ferien auf
dem bauernhof
wir müssen trotzdem obwohl wir vom
tourismus leben wollten in der schweiz
in österreich in deutschland ein
bisschen in südtirol
da und dort werden ist areale nicht
ausweisen sondern respektieren weil ich
dort eben erfahrungen und zwar radikale
erfahrungen machen kann zwischen beim
menschen natur auf der einen seite also
zum teil auch der unzivilisierten
menschennatur unterberg natur oder
bildes auf der anderen seite
und da kann ich viel direktere
erfahrungen machen erkenntnisse auch
herausholen und deswegen meine
vorstellung ok dort wo der mensch früher
ge wälder abgeholzt hat um häuser zu
bauen oder geld zu verdienen um einen
abgebrannten bauernhof wieder
aufzustellen
kann man heute auch einen kahlschlag
machen oder eine piste machen dass es
kein verbrechen
und wenn der skitourismus nicht
funktioniert dann bauten die pisten
seilbahnen ab und behalten das ganze
wieder das hat der mensch seit tausenden
von jahren gemacht aber ab einer
bestimmten höhe dort wo nichts wächst
dort wo man auch nicht liefern kann weil
die kali und die gletscher das nicht
erlauben
dort wo eigentlich nur bildnis war
dort sollten wir die berge lassen dass
sie immer waren weil sie nur als wildnis
einen wert haben unten ist es ein
ökonomischer wert wenn ich menschen
wandern lassen liefern lassen lassen und
das muss man natürlich auch vernünftigen
ausgleich machen weil die leute wollen
ja nicht kommen
von berlin oder von paris wo sie lernen
haben und stickoxide in der luft haben
und das gleiche wieder finden gibt ja
gesund sind heute wollten sich erholten
sich auch dunkeln sich auch aus bauern
mit mountainbiking oder was auch immer
aber sie wollten eine intakte landschaft
haben und er braucht ist ein kompromiss
und ich sage in den alpen oberhalb von
2300 meter vom jungfraujoch abgesehen
das ist eine kulturelle errungenschaft
ausnahme umfrage noch gemacht hat sollte
man den berg in ruhe lassen und darunter
sollte man ruhig es nutzen aber
natürlich auch in bestimmten rahmen und
hat die politik die verantwortung den
rahmen abzustecken
deswegen haben wir ja unsere
verantwortlichen die uns einen rahmen
vorgeben und wir haben uns dann als
bürger in diesem rahmen zu halten
nur wenn ich dann oberhalb des rahmens
unterwegs bin dann bin ich in einer
archaischen welt glauben gibt es die
regel lichtenberg soll diese anarchische
finden es auch bleiben ich möchte mit
ihnen noch über andere projekte sprechen
sie sind ja nicht nur hoch hinaus
sondern auch in die weite zum beispiel
haben sie die antarktis durchquert
grünland durchquert
die wüste gobi durchquert mit 60 jahren
was warum macht man das das ist doch
einfach monotonen man geht wochenlang
monatelang gerade erst drei monate war
das in der antarktis
was suchen sie da ja erstmal muss man
verstehen dass ich mich immer wieder neu
erfunden habe bis 25 war war ich ein
besessener felsklettern ich bin auch
wenn die schweiz gekommen um am ende in
europa zu klettern oder aber dann genau
beim klettern oder neue route zu
klettern nordweiler schon 68 also sehr
früh dann mit dem unfall am nanga parbat
denn wir heute schon angesprochen haben
konnte ich nicht mehr so gut an weil ich
die 10 verloren hatte nicht alle aber
doch einen größeren teil
und damit war ich gezwungen auszusteigen
ich hätte nie mehr dort anknüpfen können
wo ich mit meinen fähigkeiten vorher vor
dem rabatt war und mit einem verlust an
fähigkeiten ist mir auch leidenschaft
begeisterung abhanden gekommen und dann
bin ich nach einer zeit des zweifelns
der trauer umgestiegen nicht zur freude
der eltern und meiner brüder die wollten
dass ich mein studium fertig mache und
was sinnvolles vernünftiges machen
sinnvoll haben wir auch schon ab und
dann habe ich angefangen
höhenbergsteiger zu werden das ja nicht
völlig andere disziplin und wurde ein
höhenbergsteiger also nicht die
achttausender bestiegen hatte war
alleingänge gemacht hatte war mir klar
ich kann weder hören noch kleiner noch
im schlimmere situationen einsteigen und
damit ist mir die neugierde
abhandengekommen am ende war das ganze
ziemlich beherrscht also ich konnte das
aber damit war es auch nicht mehr eine
neue erfahrung und dann bin ich wieder
auf null gegangen habe etwas neues
gelernt das war das abenteuer in der
horizontalen und das mache ich weiter
ich bin jetzt am beginn meines lebens
und immer dann wenn ich in ein neues tun
eingestiegen bin war ich am
neugierigsten braucht ein paar jahre das
zu lernen und dann war der ehrgeiz der
tabelle da das auch aus zu stecken bis
an meine random einer möglichkeit
es gibt einen schönen satz von ihnen wo
sie sagen als sie natürlich die wüste
gobi abgereist aber sie sagen alle
wüsten dieser welt liegen zuletzt immer
in uns selbst wenn ja wie meinen sie das
ja das wieder eigentlich die großen
fragen nicht beantworten können wir
menschen sind nicht in der lage
in jenseitige zuschauen wenn es eine
welt eine wildnis auf dieser erde gibt
die uns das jenseitige vielleicht
vorgarten dann ist es die antarktis
tobel in der antarktis verschiebt sich
der horizont vor mir vielleicht fünf
kilometer senken
mit lebens schritt springt der horizont
und wenn sie das 90 92 tage haben wir
gebraucht machen dann haben sie das
gefühl die welt ist wirklich unendlich
und sie haben in jenseitige geschafft
aber sie werden nur in der antarktis
unterwegs in der gobi ist das ähnlich
und das liegt dann als wüste in uns mit
der erkenntnis wir haben keinen zugang
zum liegen wir haben keine fähigkeiten
keine keinen sinn also keine sinne keine
kann entlasten keine augen kann auch
keinen intellekt keine empathie um zu
schauen was ist nach unserem leben das
ist eine große frage beschäftigt uns
alle seit menschengedenken
wir sind schon am ende des gesprächs zum
schluss eine frage wir haben über grenz
erfahrungen über das sterben gesprochen
wie möchten sie sterben überhaupt kein
gedanke daran warum soll ich mich jetzt
gedanken machen wie ich haben möchte
ich habe meinen golfplatz vorbereitet
wir haben in italien seit kurzem die
möglichkeit bei der gemeinde zu
hinterlegen
ob wir verbrannt werden wurden oder
begraben werden worden ich lasse mich
verbrennen das ist schon festgelegt also
schriftlich festgelegt und wir dürfen
auch außerhalb des friedhofes und
bestatten
und es gibt auch die wahl einen shorten
das ist ein tibetisches grabmal für
münchen
den habe ich lange schon gebaut nicht
für diesen zweck als dann dieses gesetz
gemacht wurde mir gesagt okay da ist
bereits die höhle vorbereitet da kommt
meine ohnehin ein das ist alles aber das
kann ich festlegen aber wie ich denke
und wann ist aber das ist völlig offen
aber die zeit bis ich sterbe werde ich
weiterhin ausfüllen mit denen gehe ich
schrittchen für schrittchen umsätze denn
im umsätzen liegt eben das was andere
als glück bezeichnen
ich frage mich während des umsetzen es
niemals und glücklich bin oder nicht
denn ich bin es dann mit jeder faser wer
hinauf steigt kommt als ein anderer
zurück haben sie mal gesagt und was für
berger gilt gilt vielleicht auch für
gute gespräche
danach ist man eine andere vielen
herzlichen dank reinhold messner
dankeschön ja auch nächste woche geht es
hier um unsere freiheit und die frage
wie viel selbstbestimmung ist überhaupt
möglich und macht sie uns glücklich wie
wiederholen das gespräch meiner kollegin
barbara bleisch mit der philosophie
beate rösler
bleiben sie also dran und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]